this here is a picture of the ground
finch of the galapagos islands and one
of its primary sources of food is seeds
that it finds on the ground and if we go
back to 1976 we can look at the
distribution of beak depths and these
beak depths i would assume these are
given in millimeters
finches are quite small birds and you
can see in 1976 you have a large number
of finches that had a beak depth of 8.8
millimeters but it was a distribution
around that
now after this data was collected it
turns out there was a drought and there
were fewer seeds
so the smaller seeds which were easy to
eat for all of these finches would have
been consumed quickly and all that would
have been left were the larger seeds the
ones that you need a larger beak in
order to crack and get at the good stuff
so what do you think would have happened
to the distribution of beak depths over
the course of the next two years
well you might guess that the birds the
finches that have larger beak depths are
more likely to survive because they're
more likely to be able to crack the
larger seeds and the finches that are
more likely to survive are also more
likely to reproduce and pass their large
beak trait to their offspring and that
is indeed what scientists observed as we
go from 1976 to 1978
the distribution has shifted a pretty
good bit to the right now the most
common beak depth is 9.8
so this is an example of an
environmental change a drought changing
the food supply because now there's
fewer small seeds available that changed
a distribution in beak depths over just
two years now environmental changes
don't always cause adaptation if it's
too severe if the drought was so strong
that there were no seeds you could have
extinction so the species disappears
altogether but here we have an example
that in just two years a species was
actually unable to adapt a pretty good
bit now no individual member of the
species knew to somehow grew their beak
but as we saw you always have a
variation of beak depths and year after
year the birds with the bigger beak
depth were more likely to survive and
reproduce so the species as a whole
adapted to the new environmental
conditions